en 2018 afin de rédiger un article sur
la campagne des Jeux Olympiques à Paris
un journaliste avait demandé les notes
de frais d'Annie dalgo la transparence
la déontologie c'est un point clé de ma
pratique politique
pour lui d'obtenir ses précieux
documents de la mère de Paris beaucoup
s'interrogent et pointe alors son manque
de transparence quel exemple donnez-vous
à chaque citoyen en dafont ainsi nos
règles de droits
[Musique]
seuls les rats sont contents
ils savent qu'ici les vegan
les nourrices avec du bio le hashtag ça
cache Paris Pierre Perret a fait une
chanson pauvre Paris en Lady et tout y
passe les rats les poubelles les plastoc
jaune des affreux bitoniaux et le
mobilier urbain des bancs publics et les
fontenoyens c'était pas si dégueulasse
un titre pauvre Paris et un clip qui
divise
on sait bien qu'il t'a fait ça dans sa
chanson il s'en prend aussi bien la
pollution qu'au piste à vélo il ne nomme
pas la mère de Paris à middle Anne
Hidalgo mais il chante on sait bien
qu'il est responsable de tout cela ce
sont les crânes de Piaf qui bouffent des
graines à la mairie autrement dit les
bobos écolos elle a acheté trois Roques
dehors une à 1188 €, une à 1840 et une à
1440 une robe courge à 720 balles deux
robes Diane van fureenberg pas mal ça
c'est
Berg
et leurs accessoires une à 1660 euros et
une à 895 Anne Hidalgo nous a toujours
donné l'image d'une élue de gauche
proche du peuple qui défend les petits
qui défend qui défend les pauvres on
sort d'une précédente
mais à quel prix je connais des gens à
comprendre
très modestes surtout qu'elle est elle
remplace une municipalité qui ont
rapproché les frais de bouche réfléchira
qui est périt aussi voilà et il nous
avait dit nous on va moraliser on va
faire quelque chose de propre elle se
comporte comme une gougnafière elle a
acheté une paire de bottines qu'elle a
acheté au BHV au bazar de l'hôtel de
ville à mon avis
320 balles elle a acheté une paire de
chaussures Minelli 109 balles un manteau
apostrophe bleu marine 650 €. mais
également des pulls des pantalons des
chemisiers et des collants Monoprix
[Rires]
là on a tout hein elle est formidable je
veux dire elle a pas de limite
non mais moi j'étais persuadé je pensais
qu'elle roulait à vélo que vous voyez
qu'elle s'appliquait tout ce qu'elle
impose aux autres Parisiens dans cette
espèce de de pas de restriction mais de
pudeur et de
elle se laisse aller elle en fait elle
est conforme à ce qu'elle est c'est une
idiote
de quoi le 20 mars et la journée plus
précisément je vais regarder là-dedans
normalement c'est probablement noté
c'est le printemps non
bon expliquez-moi c'est la journée
internationale du bonheur
le nouveau cri il a l'air du GIEC dans
leur nouvelle synthèse rendue publique
aujourd'hui les experts du climat sont
formels les risques associés au
réchauffement climatique sont plus
graves que ce qui avait été estimé
jusqu'à là elle les années les plus
chaudes que le monde a connu récemment
contre parmi les plus fraîches d'ici une
génération le monde doit atteindre 0
émission net de CO2 d'ici 2050 pour
stabiliser la hausse des températures à
1,5 degrés
maintenant tu as de la sécheresse
hivernale et bah sécheresse vaginale à
moi c'est le réchauffement climatique
ma ménopause me bouffée de chaleur c'est
le réchauffement climatique non mais
faut arrêter les conneries là
franchement
[Rires]
parce que pendant un mois il a pas plu
ça y est on en sécheresse hivernal non
mais ah franchement ils sont surnommés
les messagers du printemps leur fleur
rose jaune ou blanche et clos entre mars
et avril les magnolias font chaque année
le bonheur des promeneurs je suis venu
ça fait un mois et c'était à peine à
peine fleurie et aujourd'hui je pense
que c'est super c'est les premiers à
être en fleur et puis c'est les premiers
à avoir des fleurs avant les feuilles
c'est tellement beau le printemps donc
on les voit évoluer c'est magnifique
il y a personne qui est engage dépenses
qui étaient du tout Tony Blair qui était
du tout non c'est des groupes comme
d'habitude vous êtes au courant si que
il y avait une vidéo où on voit il a
Hillary torturer une gamine
je ne comprends rien à votre couple vous
dites il en a marre
de base dans le salon à réviser
quoi on parle de la révision
j'ai malheureusement compris cette
valeur de son côté Trump ni avoir couché
avec stormy Daniel ce qui le prend mal
et fait la tournée des émissions pour
livrer tous les détails de sa nuit avec
lui
c'est aussi un film sur une revanche
il se bat pour sa liberté et se sentir
en paix
j'aime bien sa détermination j'adore la
vengeance oui oui ça fait du bien de se
venger
à 43 ans Fabrice se connaît bien et il
est très précis sur ce qu'il cherche
chez une femme je cherche une nana qui
soit gémeaux ascendant scorpion et qui
chauffe un 37 donc c'est pas non plus
très compliqué
[Rires]
mais avec plein de courage
osez nous rencontrer en télé sans même
l'avoir tenté en privé
[Musique]
quel début inattendu pour une femme
détestant le superflu mais désireuse de
vouloir employer ensemble le mot union
avec un grand u tandis que par moment
j'avais peut-être juste envie de te
bouffer le
stormy Daniel's a indiqué si le
champignon de Trump ressemblait plutôt à
un tout petit cèpe ou à une grosse
trompette de la mort
oh
[Applaudissements]